السعاده والاكتئاب هل يمكن ان تجمع علاقه
بين هذين الشعيرين في اوروبا منظمه
التعاون الاقتصادي والتنميه تكشف ان الدول
الاوروبيه الاكثر سعاده هي الاكثر
استهلاكا للمضادات الاكتئاب بالفعلوا على
غير المتوقع ارقام المنظمه اوضحت ان
متوسطه استهلاك مضادات الاكتئاب في 18
دوله اوروبيه ارتفع بمقدار مرتين ونصف حتى
20 20 الاغرب في هذه الدراسه اكثر الدول
استهلاكا كانت ايسلندا رغم ان الدوله
مصنفه من الدول السعيده بسبب الطقس شديد
البروده ربما لكن ما التفسيرات المحتمله
الاخرى لهذا الارتفاع المتضاعف بهذا الشكل
واين نحن من هذه الارقام
[موسيقى]
مع ارتفاع نسبه تعطيها هل يمكن القول
بالفعل ان العالم اليوم مدمن على حبوب
كتير
واخذ الادويه النفسيه اخر الادويه النفسيه
بغالبيتها العظمى ليست ادويه ادمانيه هي
ادويه علاجيه تعطى لاسباب معينه لفتره
معينه لمساعده
المراجع على التخلص من اعراض يعاني منها
وربما مساعدته في اتخاذ قرارات واجراءات
قد يكون بحاجه الى هل يغير حياته وهي ليست
ادمانيا هذا يختلف جدا عن شيء اسمه التعلق
العاطفي اللي بيحدث عند امهاتنا مثلا اللي
تقول انا اذا ما اشرب فنجان القهوه او
كاسه الشاي يجيني صداع برغم انه ما في
علاقه بين الصداع والقهوه لكن في نوع من
التعلق عند امي وامكم انه اذا ما شربت هذا
الشيء وهي طالعه على السوق راح يجيها صداع
فلذلك هي الادويه ليست ادمانيه اساءه
استخدامها شيء اخر مختلف بس انا بدي اعرف
كيف بدي اعرف اني انا وصلت لمرحله
الاكتئاب وليست مرحله نكد او الشعور
بفقدان الشغف لا مبالاه مثلا اسمحي لي
اجاوبك مرتين الجواب الاول انه في اليه في
شروط يجب توفرها بضمنها حاله الحزن وفقدان
الاهتمام اضطرابات الوزن اضطرابات النوم
الافكار السلبيه الانعزال من المجتمع
اساءه استخدام المواد كلها هذه يجب ان
تحدث على مدى اسبوعين ثلاث مرات خلال ست
شهور مش لانه اليوم نسيتي او صدمتي سيارتك
او نسيت المحافظ
انا اذا اكثر من اسبوعين وتكرر وهذا الفرق
بينه وبين انه انت مثلا تفقدي شيء مهم
وتحسي انه انت حزينه لفتره معينه ثم تطلعي
من هذا الشيء لانه انت عندك مقاومه للضغط
الخارجيه ال ال دق الاخر اللي الان بدينا
ننتبه عليه بزياده بسبب زياده الوعي
وخصوصا عند جيل الشباب والمراهقين انه
بدات التركيز مش بس على المشاعر انما على
الشغب ان هم بداوا يشعروا انه هو صح
الاكتئاب موجود لكن هم نفسهم بدو- يفقدوا
الاهتمام ويفقدوا الرغبه بان يقوم باشياء
كانت تشعرهم بالسعاده سابقا مثل العمل مثل
الرياضه مثل الحياه الاجتماعيه بس حتى بعض
الاحيان الحياه الزوجيه